Nami betrayed Luffy.
Sanji abandoned him and beat him up.
And Robin framed Luffy for assassination.
In all these circumstances, Luffy forgave
his crewmates because of his kind heart and
his faith in their relationships.
But can you imagine what another pirate would
have done in these situations.
What would the main antagonist Blackbeard
have done?
Or the ruthless Captain Kid?
Well, what would have happened if instead
of being kind-hearted and loving, Luffy was
power-hungry and evil?
Starting with chapter one when Luffy is first
inspired to become a great pirate by Shanks.
This part of the story remains mostly the
same, except for one key difference.
Luffy is still captured by bandits.
Shanks still rescues Luffy and loses his arm,
and the iconic straw hat still gets passed
down to Luffy.
However, the small difference comes when Shanks
tells Luffy that cannot join his crew.
In the original, Shanks tells Luffy that he
is too young to join the crew.
But for the purpose of this video, Shanks
is going to tell Luffy that he is NOT STRONG
ENOUGH to join the Red Hair Pirates.
And this small change is going to make Luffy
believe that he can only become a great pirate
by becoming that most powerful.
And while already somewhat believes this idea,
for this video Luffy is taking it to an extreme
level.
And he’ll also learn from Lucky Roux that
in this world you must kill or be killed.
And you won’t believe how this small change
is going to affect the battle at Marineford
later on.
For now, Shanks still leaves Dawn Island and
Luffy spends ten years training before setting
out to gather his pirate crew.
And unlike the other What If videos we’ve
done on this channel such as What if Luffy
had the Admiral’s Devil Fruits or What if
Luffy Joined Shanks’ crew, we are going
to spend significant time focused on the East
Blue because the dynamics of the Straw Hat
crew are going to massively change.
So Luffy sets out, eager to gather a crew
and fight anyone in his path.
He still loves to have fun and party.
He still wants to become the pirate king.
And he still has a way of convincing people
to follow him.
However, now he is a power-hungry pirate.
He is more cold-hearted and he has less emotional
intelligence.
Plus, he is willing to kill and he only wants
crewmates who are strong or useful to his
crew.
The first person Luffy meets is this pink
haired kid, Koby.
Luffy mocks the enslaved deck swab for being
such a weakling.
Luffy still clobbers Alvida and sets him free,
but instead of becoming Luffy’s friend,
this wanna-be marine now vows to one day take
down Luffy himself.
Next up is Shell Island.
Here Luffy would easily defeat the corrupt
marine captain Morgan and he would probably
laugh at seeing Zoro all tied up.
Luffy would probably release Zoro after learning
that Zoro is a famous bounty hunter and then
challenges him to a duel.
And even though swords are Luffy’s main
weakness, he would probably defeat Zoro because
the swordsman is weak from not eating for
so long.
However, Luffy is impressed by Zoro’s strength
and instead of killing him, Luffy invites
Zoro to join his crew.
Which Zoro accepts because growing stronger
is also his main goal.
The pair then travel to Orange Town, where
the story essentially plays out the same.
Luffy defeats Buggy and he lets Nami come
along because she is a badass navigator, something
the crew desperately needs.
And Nami would want to join because she can
steal Luffy's treasure later on.
And speaking of treasure, this version of
Luffy would take most of the treasure from
Buggy instead of leaving it for the ruined
town.
So even with the changes to Luffy, we still
have our first two crewmates.
And they would likely seek out other pirates
to fight and pillage before landing at Usopp’s
hometown, Syrup Village.
And this is where we have our first major
change to the story.
After defeating the fake-butler Kuro, Luffy
never invites Usopp to join the crew because
of his weak fighting capabilities.
So sorry Usopp fans, our sniper stays at Syrup
Village.
But at least he gets the girl.
And no Usopp means no Merry, so Luffy and
the crew will need to steal a different ship
somewhere along the way.
Next up is the Baratie, where the story takes
a dramatic turn for the worse.
The crew would still defeat this guy no problem,
but things get really interesting when the
world’s strongest swordsman Mihawk shows
up.
Because a battle-hungry Luffy would never
let Zoro have all the fun fighting such a
strong opponent.
And there are a lot of ways that this battle
could go, but none of them are good for the
Straw Hats.
We already saw Zoro almost die from this encounter
and it could be even worse for Luffy because
of his weakness to blades.
It is likely he could lose an arm or leg in
this fight, but let’s just assume that he
gets a similar massive injury like Zoro which
means that the crew must stay at the Baratie
while they heal.
And during this time, Luffy convinces Sanji
to pursue his dreams of finding the All Blue,
so the cook joins the crew as well.
But this prolonged recovery leaves Nami with
the perfect chance to betray Luffy.
She steals the treasure, and the ship, and
returns to her home island where she hopes
to pay for her village’s freedom.
This leaves Luffy pissed off by not only his
defeat to Mihawk, but that his crewmate would
betray him.
So we head to Arlong Park, where an enraged
Luffy storms in, defeats the fishman Arlong
who is terrorizing Nami’s village.
And Luffy is furious that Nami betrayed him.
He could even threaten to destroy her village
himself, but let’s assume that he eventually
allows her to rejoin because he respects what
she was doing to protect her people and her
use to the crew.
Certainly, that takes a different kind of
strength.
But now Nami and Luffy’s relationship is
much shallower than it was in the original
story.
So while Luffy is still saving islands from
other bad pirates, he is not gaining as many
friends and allies because he is fighting
for selfish reasons.
Keep watching to see how this will become
a fatal flaw later on.
At this point, we’ve got the whole crew
minus Usopp as they reach Logue Town, the
last island before the Grand Line.
Here Luffy is never captured by Buggy because
well, Buggy is no longer alive.
Yikes…
But Luffy is still helpless to fight the marine
captain Smoker, who ate the Smoke logia devil
fruit.
Luffy is still saved by his father dragon,
but the defeat leaves Luffy desperate to learn
how to fight Logia devil fruit users.
So instead of a party as the crew enters the
Grand Line, an angry Luffy is just determined
to get stronger.
Now the first person they meet in the Grand
Line is the former pirate king’s doctor,
Crocus.
And being a former Roger pirate means that
he would surely know the basics of haki.
So with the defeat to Smoker still on his
mind, Luffy convinces Crocus to teach him
how to defeat Logia fruit users.
This would require some time, but eventually
the crew would learn the basics of Armament
and Observation haki.
And damn that’s going to make a huge difference
to every single fight ahead.
Vivi, the princess of Alabasta, might still
tag along with the hope that Luffy could save
her kingdom.
She could even tempt Luffy with the promise
of a strong opponent to fight on her home
island.
However, when the crew arrives on Drum Island,
I don’t think they could convince Chopper
to join them because Luffy would care more
about his monstrous powers instead of his
capabilities as a doctor.
So no Chopper, but they do recruit some random
doctor to join their crew.
Next they travel to Alabasta, where Luffy
is itching to fight another warlord of the
sea after his defeat by Mihawk.
And now that Luffy knows the basics of Haki,
his fight with Crocodile goes much smoother.
He can actually punch the Sand logia fruit
user and eventually manages to defeat him.
So with Crocodile down, we now reach another
interesting crossroads.
While I think Robin would definitely join
the crew, she would probably consider the
straw hats to just be another group of bad
guys that she would stay with to progress
her own plans.
But the more interesting questions would be
what happens with Crocodile?
You see, we have many examples of other strong
pirates recruiting defeated pirates to their
crew.
For example, the Emperor of the Sea, Kadio,
tried to recruit Luffy after defeating the
straw hat captain in Wano.
So while it is possible Crocodile could be
arrested by the marines, this version of Luffy
invites him to join the crew because he is
a powerful fighter.
So with two new crewmates from Alabasta, we
continue to Jaya, and the fateful meeting
with the darkness logia fruit user Blackbeard.
After Luffy makes an example out of this springy
pirate he would certainly challenge Blackbeard
to a fight.
Blackbeard would welcome this because he is
already trying to capture Luffy to turn him
into the World Government.
And with Luffy’s warped personality, these
two have actually become very similar.
They are both hungry for power.
They both believe in their dreams and are
willing to do whatever it takes to achieve
them.
And most importantly, they are both subscribed
to this channel.
But would you believe me if I told you that
this similarity will lead them to joining
forces later on?
Keep watching to find out why.
But for now, we will assume that their fight
essentially ends in a draw, and the straw
hats fly up to the sky islands.
Here they defeat the lightning fruit user
Enel much easier because of Luffy’s rubber
body but also because of their experience
with haki.
Luffy could even try to recruit Enel, but
I imagine Enel would probably decline.
And at this point, Luffy’s bounty is significantly
higher than it was during the original story.
Luffy’s obsession with strength would likely
mean he doesn’t worry about causing destruction.
So similarly to his rival Eustass kid, his
bounty would rise even higher.
Next the straw hats face one of their toughest
challenges yet, the admiral Aokiji.
The chilly fruit user has come to reclaim
Robin, and he is simply too much for the crew
to take on.
And this leads to an interesting dilemma.
Since this version of Luffy has much less
of a bond with his crewmates, it is possible
he could abandon Robin.
However, much like he welcomed Nami back,
in this case he surprisingly decides to challenge
the admiral one on one for Robin’s freedom.
And Luffy wouldn’t be as overwhelmed as
he was in chapter 321.
This version of Luffy is stronger and knows
haki, but he would still lose and have to
be saved by the crew’s doctor.
But this takes us to Water 7, where the crew
still needs a new ship after their crazy descent
from Skypiea.
This arc plays out similar to the original.
Luffy already put his neck on the line for
Robin when he fought Aokiji, so he isn’t
going to let the World Government take her
now.
So the arc ends with Franky making them a
new ship before he joins the crew.
And as an added bonus, Luffy is much more
interested in Franky’s weapons and he demands
more guns on the new ship.
In their new ship, the straw hats seek out
fights with other strong pirates and marines
in the Grand Line before eventually reaching
the zombie infested floating island, Thriller
Bark.
Here Luffy stomps the warlord Gecko Moria,
and Brook joins the crew.
And since the crew as a whole is much stronger,
they are also able to escape from the warlord
Kuma without much trouble.
But next is Sabaody where the straw hats suffer
an EVEN WORSE defeat than they did in the
original story.
In Chapter 506, we meet this old man, Silver
Rayleigh, who was the right hand of the former
pirate king.
And Rayleigh has actually been waiting for
Luffy since the time Shanks told him about
a certain kid who resembled their former captain,
Roger.
And originally, Rayleigh helps the crew as
they prepare to enter the New World.
But in this version, things are much different.
Both Rayleigh and Shanks have heard of Luffy's
cold-hearted journey through the Grand Line
and they now believe that Luffy is not fit
to wear the straw hat.
This leads Rayleigh to demand that Luffy change
his ways or give up the hat.
Luffy, of course, wouldn’t pay him any attention,
which would lead to a mind-blowing confrontation.
Rayleigh challenges Luffy for the right to
the hat.
And Luffy accepts.
Of course, Rayleigh, who was said to be nearly
as strong as the former pirate king himself,
would destroy Luffy and take the hat from
Luffy’s unconscious head.
Bet you didn’t have that on your bingo card.
This result could send the story in many different
ways.
The first route we are going to explore has
Luffy staying on Sabaody where he vows to
take the straw hat back from Rayleigh.
However, it is also at this time that the
World Government announces that Luffy’s
brother, Ace, is going to be executed.
So Luffy and the crew head to Marineford.
And just as much as Luffy wants to free Ace,
he is equally excited to fight all the crazy
strong marines and pirates who are coming
to the war.
The straw hats arrive at Marineford just as
the battle is underway.
And while this version of the straw hats are
definitely stronger than they were in the
original story, they are still no match for
the combined might of Mihawk, the cyborg Pacifistas,
and the marine admirals.
In this situation, it is also likely that
the Emperor of the Sea, Whitebeard, would
not trust Luffy.
So instead of being allies, they get in each
other’s way.
This leads to Ace being executed as planned,
meaning Luffy failed even more miserably than
in the original story.
Perhaps a fitting lesson that the pursuit
of power will not always get you what you
want.
Assuming Luffy lives, he would likely be devastated
over the loss of his brother and humiliated
that he was too weak to save him.
This could send him into an even deeper spiral
where he becomes more desperate for power.
This mindset would set him on a similar track
to the last man that tried to take over the
world, Rocks D. Xebec.
While we don’t know much about this pirate,
we do know he was insanely powerful and tried
to kill the world nobles.
I think this Luffy would take the same path
AND meet the same end, where he would be killed
in battle, never having regained his straw
hat.
Now, let’s back all the way up to after
Luffy’s defeat to Rayleigh.
From here, options two and three follow mostly
the same route.
In the original story, Luffy punched this
world noble for trying to enslave his mermaid
friend.
While this version of Luffy wouldn’t necessarily
care about the slavery, I think his frustration
after losing to Rayleigh could very easily
cause him to attack a world noble anyway.
Just like in the main story, this would summon
the marines, the cyborg Pacifistas, and the
admiral Kizaru to take out the straw hats.
And while they might be able to survive the
Pacifistas and even Kuma, who they already
escaped from on Thriller Bark, in this version
Rayleigh would not save them from Kizaru.
So Luffy would be captured, thrown in the
underwater prison, Impel Down, and erased
from the story.
Or… not quite.
Remember this is also around the time that
Blackbeard breaks into Impel Down to recruit
strong criminals to his crew.
So let’s assume that Ace is still taken
to Marineford, Blackbeard overthrows the prison,
and he takes the strongest prisoners with
him.
Including, are you ready…?
Luffy.
That’s right.
Evil Luffy and Blackbeard are on the same
crew.
For now.
So, the Blackbeard pirates travel to Marineford
with the goal of killing Whitebeard and taking
his devil fruit.
However, this is where Luffy goes wild because
at this point Ace has already been executed.
Luffy realizes that he failed to save his
brother because he was locked in jail.
This causes him to lose his mind.
He starts to fight anyone in his path.
Admirals, Whitebeard’s commanders, Warlords
of the Sea.
He would probably even awaken his conquerors
haki due to his immense rage.
However, this is when Shanks shows up to stop
the war.
Shanks demands that everyone stops fighting.
And while the Marines and other pirates pull
back, Luffy refuses to quit.
Shanks is also wearing Luffy’s straw hat,
and, in a rush of madness, Luffy challenges
Shanks to a duel for the hat.
Now, consider how Shanks would be feeling
at this moment.
He is facing the kid who he once trusted with
his treasured straw hat.
The kid who he hoped would grow up to become
the pirate king.
But now standing before him is a twisted version
who has been driven mad by his lust for power.
Shanks initially tries to talk Luffy out of
fighting, but Luffy will not give up and eventually
Shanks agrees, hoping that he can teach Luffy
a lesson and get him to change his ways.
But if they do fight, this version of Luffy
simply has no chance of defeating Shanks.
And here is where we can split off into our
two final options for this Luffy's future.
One way this could go is that Shanks takes
down Luffy, but as we’ve seen so often in
the story, Luffy refuses to stay down.
Even if Shanks begs him to stop, Luffy won’t
quit.
He keeps coming for Shanks and the Red Hair
pirates, and ultimately Shanks is left with
no choice.
He kills the enraged Luffy.
And you might ask why Shanks would kill Luffy.
Well if Shanks thinks that Luffy would be
a danger to the world, similar to Rocks, then
it would make sense for him to put Luffy down.
And this takes us to a third path, and the
one we will explore more fully.
Let’s imagine that Luffy has been knocked
down by Shanks again and again.
Shanks’ blade rests on Luffy’s neck, and
finally, the rubber boy breaks down in tears.
He lets all of his anger and his frustrations.
He thinks back on his journey so far, and
all the cold-hearted things he’s done.
And he finally realizes that he HAS lost his
way.
After losing his brother in this battle, he
realizes that he cannot keep living like this.
He wants to care about the people around him
and regrets not caring more about his crew.
Seeing this, Shanks offers Luffy a choice.
Come away from Marineford with him and to
learn how to be a great captain.
Or die.
Luffy accepts his former mentor’s offer
and after some time spent with the Red Hair
pirates, he reunites with his crew.
And this takes us to the time skip.
But now instead of spending the two years
training separately, the crew spends the time
bonding and forming the real relationships
that they had in the original story.
After the time skip, the story would continue
much as it had in the original story, only
with a few of the crew members missing.
Luffy and crew advance through the New World
now with Luffy’s greatest power.
His ability to inspire others with his joyfulness,
his friendship, and his selflessness.
Which is a lesson he had to learn the hard
way because he tried to overcome everything
with strength and power, but he failed.
In the end he was not strong enough and he
nearly lost everything, including his brother
at Marineford.
But this leads to an even more interesting
question.
What if Luffy was strong enough at Marineford?
Could he have saved Ace if he had his current
storyline powers?
In other words, what would happen if Gear
5 Luffy was at Marineford?
If you want to find out, click this video
right here.
Shanks for watching.